sigma notation this is something that
you have
actually i'm 90 sure that 90
of you have encountered however might
have been a little bit
of a while ago you would have met it
potentially in series and sequences last
term
and also within the advanced course
in statistics in discrete random
variables but
that was a little bit time ago so i'm
going to try and refresh
your memory we're in mathematical
induction as you recall
today and friday will be our last
lessons within this
and then delight of delight 3d vector
land is where we're headed so that's
just a bit of a
teaser but we can prove induction
results like the ones you can see over
there in fact these are going to be
the bulk of our lesson today and sigma
notation gives us a really nice succinct
way to
articulate what these results are so
let's see if you can remember what's
going on here
this greek letter sigma this is a
capital sigma by the way
the lowercase sigma which you might
remember from your calculator looks like
that
the capital sigma it's an s for sum
we're adding things up right so this is
just like the induction you did in
extension one
we frequently handled uh you know
series of terms and then we would say
well if it's true for k
prove it for k plus one so what does
this mean let's just make sure we got a
handle on this right
we're adding up things of this form 1
over 2n plus 1 to n minus 1
such that n takes on these particular
values you start at this bottom one here
in fact i might even label this just so
you've got some helpful reminders
you start at this bottom value there's
your start value
as it were when you see this
sigma that's a signal to you that just
like in discrete random variables
we're dealing with whole numbers here
you start down the bottom
in this case lowercase n equals one and
then you end
up here this is your end value
okay so for instance i could specify
capital n
equals five in which case i would
evaluate this expression here
for one and then i add it to this
expression for two
and then three and then four and then i
would terminate
on five or whatever i happen to have so
let's just make sure we understand this
and write out
a few terms right what will be the very
first one
1 over and then i'm going to pop in the
appropriate values here
what's the beginning value for lowercase
n
it's 1. so if lowercase n equals 1 then
this first
set of brackets will equal two plus one
which is three
and then this one here will be two minus
one which is
one cool so i've got there's my
lowercase n equals one
and then i add two lowercase n equals
two right
by the way if you're wondering why i
chose a lowercase n and a capital n
i didn't this is the example out the
syllabus and i'm like why give me two
n's
anyway it's not that unusual but i would
have chosen other letters if it wasn't
my my peak
the next one over lowercase n equals two
it's still going to be one over
but what will my denominator have this
time
when i put in lowercase n equals two i
get
five times 3. now of course you know
that 5 times 3
equals 15 but the whole point here the
reason we're writing these terms out
is so we can establish a pattern in fact
as we get this
third and last one to set up my um to
establish my pattern
maybe you don't even need to go back to
this thing you can see what's happening
to each of these two terms in the
denominator
each of these independent terms is think
back to your series and sequences
language from last year right
if you think about this as lowercase n
goes one two three
four what kind of sequence of terms are
you getting here it's an
arithmetic sequence right in fact
they're both arithmetic sequences
uh so i'm going to get three and then
five and then seven
one and then three and then five you
with me
got the pattern now of course this
particular sippy notation i'm not ending
at uh this is n equals one n equals two
n equals three
i'm ending at n equals capital m so i
should say
plus dot dot dot and then i am going to
write my very last one okay
this one actually takes the least effort
of all because
instead of lowercase ns i'm just going
to substitute in
capital ns is that okay so let's go
ahead and write that capital
and capital n again
fantastic so this is me trying to review
for you what does sigma notation mean
you're adding up this series of terms
that all have this
format it's actually a little bit like
function notation in that way like this
is our
f of n if you like and we're just
putting in the right values
i'm just going to pause there for a
moment now that you have this reminder
of what segmentation is
we're going to prove this by induction
the first two steps of your induction
are
pretty straightforward you're going to
need to test the base case which in this
case is
it's the base case it's going to be one
right go ahead and test it make sure it
works
we're going to assume that this thing
this statement is actually true
for some arbitrary value n equals k then
the real work will begin when we try and
prove the
k plus one step okay so can i hit pause
there
see if you can make a start the testing
that you assume should be able to do
without too much challenge
go ahead and do the k plus one step and
then we'll come back together all right
i assume many of you are making some
headway through the k plus one step you
may have even got to the end of it
already well done
uh this was not too arduous an example
to begin with but just in case
uh you're not on the same page have a
look at the screen here's my test
and my assume step now just be watchful
you can see here the particular variable
the thing that's changing and
incrementing is actually the capital n
that's it sneaky isn't it usually it's
the lowercase n but you can see that's
what i'm changing in the first
instance and that's what i'm
substituting for the n equals k which i
have let me just scroll a little bit
there's my assumption that i'm going to
use okay now i began
just to remind you what simulation was
by doing
what should we call this unrolling sigma
notation like
fully expanding it out getting all the
terms there but you can see this is
quite an arduous and long way to do this
right it's
rather inefficient to write everything
out that's the whole point of having
this very compact succinct way of saying
things okay so for my
proof of this statement being true for
the k plus one
case i'm going to do my best to try and
not
unroll it save myself some time but
still employ
the same logic so having a look at this
usually usually we remember in a proof
by induction we can choose
is the left hand side easier to work
with or the right hand side or if it was
an inequality do we do some left hand
side take away right hand
side business when you have a look at
this this is the
k plus one statement which i want to
prove which side looks like it's easier
to work with
another way to say that which side looks
easier
to be able to use the inductive
hypothesis the assumption any takers
i i reckon the left-hand side right this
right-hand side
it looks like it's the end point after
having done a whole bunch of
simplification
okay so rather than take a simple thing
and complicate it which
sometimes you have to do you've got no
choice let's start with this thing
and then we can use our assumption
fairly easily okay so here comes the
proof
let's consider the left hand side
now i'm just going to take as given that
this is
what it is right now because we're going
from n equals 1 up to
k plus 1 you can imagine if i did this
right
if i did this up here i would start from
1 and then 2 and then 3
i'd get to k and then i'd go one more
yeah that'd be the k plus one bit right
so as a result what i can do is take
all of the first k terms and i can just
write that
in sigma notation that's what my
assumption is do you agree
so let's write the first k terms it's
going to be sigma notation
from 1 to k of this particular fraction
that i've got here 1 over
okay now there's the first k terms but
the left-hand side of my
thing that i'm trying to prove that
doesn't just have k terms it has this
extra one right so i'm going to have to
write the k
plus one term along the end i'm gonna
have to say
plus whatever this looks like when i
substitute in k
plus one so easy part is the numerator
nothing much going on there
what's the denominator gonna look like
when i put k plus one in this first set
of brackets
what's it simplify two k plus three
fantastic so
chuck that in brackets here and then
what about the second set of brackets
two k plus one because it's two k
plus two minus one with me okay
now because i have this assumption over
here uh from my earlier step
this one here right i can just
substitute this
for my assumption which i think is what
is it k on to k
plus one and of course
we want to say that we're doing that
that we're actually invoking
the assumption right so what's our
normal phrase we're doing that
what do we say from the inductive
hypothesis by assumption any of those
are fine
yeah i'll just write this because it's
the shortest
now i'm so confident at this point that
you'll be okay
that i'm not even going to complete the
proof because this
what we've just turned this nightmarish
kind of question into
this is like eighth
grade algebra for you guys i reckon you
can manage this right what are you gonna
do like don't
write it just talk me through it what's
the next step from here common
denominator common denominator i've
already got half of a common denominator
over here
2k plus 1 is done so in fact all i need
to do
is say 2k plus 3
if it's on the top uh sorry if it's on
the bottom better be on the top as well
this is going to add to here because
you've got this common
denominator already okay now have a look
at where we're headed whoops
here's where we're headed how am i going
to get there
yeah there's going to be cancelling
happening right when you
this is going to give you 2k squared
plus 3k
plus 1 and you can factorize that it's
just a standard quadratic
in k and the right things will cancel
and you'll be done does that make sense